so here's another story a while back I
heard a story about some user tests that
were being run and though it was slick
for an interface for a washing machine
or something and there was some problem
that users could encounter that was
incredibly frustrating was a little bit
of an edge case but it was incredibly
frustrating they lose a lot of time be
really confused right and the testers
the the designers were working on this
project went to the engineers and said
hey this is a big problem mm-hmm we
should fix this and the engineer said
that's not a problem people don't
actually do that all right because
engineers are smart right and the
designers you know said no we've seen
people do this like this is it this is a
big problem you should fix this and
engineers go all right you know we'll
put it in the backlog which means you
know they mayor never actually get
around to it and so the designers went
back to the users and did a bunch more
user tests and recorded the users and
took video of the users having this
problem and then saying what just
happened this is so confusing and then
strung I think it was like 30 to 50 of
these users having this problem in a row
together sat all the engineers in a
conference room and played the video and
when you're sitting in a conference room
watching a video of real people have
real problems with your products it's a
lot harder to ignore those problems and
if it's just some person saying they saw
somebody maybe have a problem with this
once right so more of a story take video
show it to people it's the most powerful
communication tool that you have right
thank you